okay now don't tell me answer but hands
up if you've got an answer for this
hands up hands up straight one c
evaluate that definitely one c heads up
ends up now if you have an answer you'll
be confident of your answer like you'll
know it's right
okay if you're like i don't think i
really have an answer you probably don't
have the answer okay
um so let's have a look at the question
and why is it so confusing okay
so you've got this
now as i walked around this is quite
amusing i looked
this is what i was picking up your
pieces of paper for some of you
i couldn't do it um i'd look and you
kind of you write down this
and then some of you have written down
you know this
and then let's go on to question d
guys um
what do you do with that now what's the
problem what's the problem
uh the problem is that that's not a
function that we're familiar with we
don't know what the primitive
is it's not a standard form it's not on
the table standard integrals which i
didn't give you but even an idea would
not help you with this question
okay and to perplexion even more
it's worth one mark you're like what
kind of black magic kind of a technique
gets this
in one mark okay so you know it's simple
in some way
but if you didn't get answered you
didn't work out what the way what
so knowing that you don't know the
primitive of this okay and you should be
confident enough to say
sine cubed what is that you know how am
i supposed to know what that is you're
not
okay so therefore this simple method
must have to do with
something that doesn't have to do with
the primitive okay
now what kind of question is this this
is a definite integral
right so really in disguise even though
they don't work this way it's a question
about an area of some kind
oh snap and the question is what kind of
area
is it now it is a simple area but you
can't just write down the answer even
though it is
on one marker okay how would we how
would we explain
this is ridiculous how would we explain
that the answer is this function is an
odd function so let's give this a go
now to justify why this is
okay you might have because it was just
one mark you might even be able to get
away with just saying that but if it was
two
you'd need to provide some reasoning for
what okay so how would you do it okay
yeah
but it doesn't say it's imperial it
doesn't
need to okay the reason why is because
see this is what it's testing
do you understand that what an integral
a definite integral
really is it really is an area okay so
this is trying to
i hate the phrase because it's very it's
very misogynist but it's trying to sort
out the men from the boys
the people who just like oh yeah i know
i do the mechanical process and
those are the people who write down that
and then like oh
okay so how am i going to justify okay
well how do we normally prove
that functions are odd for mine
yeah okay so i'm going to need to say
let's call this something
okay okay so let's call that
f right now if it's an odd function what
i'm expecting is what is the
characteristic
minus x if you want an area that means
you have to absolutely
ah don't assume you have to i've always
said be careful with absolute values
right i've always said be careful you
can't just throw them in willy-nilly
now it's an area but it hasn't said you
know
find the area of which means that this
will give you a negative
right or is it positive i haven't
checked but it's going to give you
opposites either way
okay so how do i justify that it's odd
if that if that's f of x then
i want to work out what f of minus x is
right
so let's substitute this is minus
x squared sine
cubed of minus x right
well minus x whole squared the negatives
cancel and then what do you get here
well sine is an odd function right so
that's why
this is going to have a minus sign
there's actually
three minus signs in there because it's
cubed right so minus minus minus
negative
one okay so minus x squared sine
cubed and that is our definition of
another function
okay because this is even about yeah
yeah
how do you improve it yeah so i reckon
for one mark you probably got away with
it okay
but i could just they could just as
easily have made this a two-mark
question and then you'd expect it to
do something like this and then here
you'd either say
as x squared sine
sine cubed x is odd
or you could alternatively you could say
by symmetry because
odd means symmetry